after President Trump gave his State of  the Union address House Speaker Nancy  Pelosi tore it in half tore it in half  crazy yeah yeah then Melania said great  now do my prenup  last night President Trump put in some  sort of reality TV moments did you see  that I did that last night President  Trump surprised a woman in the audience  by bringing her husband back from active  duty yes yeah the woman was surprised  and so was her boyfriend Steve from  these a barista early earlier today  President Trump you probably saw this  earlier today President Trump was  acquitted in his impeachment trial yeah  yeah yeah I know he he's celebrated by  calling Ukraine and asking for dirt on  Joe Biden that's just how he relax yeah  yeah oh wait I'm not supposed to do this  New York jurors today were shown naked  photos of Harvey Weinstein yeah in a  related story no one will ever go to  jury duty again  [Applause]